if you're looking to make this the year
to focus on improving your body blue
point medical spa can help
mercedes introduces us to two of the
services that they offer
to help you lose weight and tone your
way into 2021
you can make 2021 the year that you
finally meet some of those goals
like losing some of that extra fat you
may have put on maybe you want to tone
up and we're at blue point medical spa
i have jennifer and melissa here to show
us how we can do that with some really
innovative
new methods what is this method here
that we have for fat reduction
well this is called the vanquish and the
vanquish
helps to reduce fat now how does it do
this this looks like the machine is kind
of going over the body and it's it's
all encompassing it's not just one
specific area it's got your whole
stomach area exactly um that's one thing
great about
the vanquish is that when we're using
the treatment
it's using the it's doing the flank and
the stomach area
so what it does it basically takes radio
frequency or
it's basically heat and it hovers over
the area
and it goes to about 120 degrees and
when it does it takes that fat cell
and it basically like dissolves it
that's fantastic because i've seen other
fat reduction machines before that like
pinch you and it's painful but
she's just laying there enjoying the
treatment she's very
comfortable she can just take a nap and
it's not affecting you know any of our
organs it's just basically
like a nice warm massage how many
treatments usually does it take to see
some results on something like this
well we recommend four treatments
and you do it once a week now what kind
of results have you seen with something
like this
what i've seen with our clients is about
two to two and a half
inches in diameter loss now we want to
do
some sculpting some toning and tell us
about this machine
well this machine is called m-sculpt and
what it does it
basically takes a high intensity
electromagnetic
and it focuses on the areas of the
muscle and you can hear
it's like a pulsing sound yes so which
is in essence is she doing like
thousands and thousands of sit-ups right
now but just by laying there
well basically it's just taking the
electromagnetic pulses and is doing
about 20 000 pulses in 30 minutes so you
could come in
on your lunch break and have basically a
workout
in 30 minutes as you can see we are all
wearing masks here and blue point
medical spa really takes precautions
when it comes to protecting customers
who come in during these coveted times
tell everyone what you guys do
well we have our office sprayed three
times a week
and then we wipe all services down in
between each client
very clean very safe environment to get
these procedures done
now let's talk about the price of these
procedures you guys what
really recommend that you get a series
of four for each one the m sculpt and
the vanquish
how much does each package cost well
each package
um for the m sculpt is four for two
thousand
and then for the vanquish it's four for
a thousand
great way to kick off the new year toned
and losing some fat that blue point
medical spa
blue point medical spa is located at
3320 north
buffalo drive suite 103 you can call
them at that phone number 702-307-3330
or find them online
bluepointmedicalspa.com
take advantage of the promotions get
four vanquish treatments for
a thousand bucks and four of their em
sculpt treatments
for two thousand rocky